well here are some do's and don'ts in
case you are the single man in illinois
who won the billion dollars do follow
your dreams for cowboy neil wamless
allowed him to live comfortably while
pursuing his passions he bought a nearly
50 000 acre ranch in south dakota he
told wall street journal that he stayed
grounded thanks to the rewarding
challenges of life on the range oh my
god i love that don't dream recklessly
okay 19 year old jonathan vargas won 35
million powerball prize in 2008 he
created
restless takedown an all-female
wrestling tv show i'm embarrassed for
that man like i really am like he should
be ashamed do give wisely
true don't be too generous
irish winner peter lavery is still rich
and said that he has received thousands
of letters asking for financial support
he said earn them
ignore them don't open anything if you
don't know who it's from right because
of course it's going to pull out your
heart